augmented reality is growing in
popularity and in this course you will
learn how to develop AR apps by building
practical projects the course consists
of four different augmented reality
projects which are built on top of unity
engine and AR Foundation the projects
will help you explore various Fields
such as engineering education e-commerce
and creativity priyanshu developed this
course he has a lot of experience
developing AR apps and he's created
other popular courses on the topic and
this free course we are gonna explore
the possibilities of Augmented Reality
by building such captivating and
practical augmented reality experiences
we will start with Planet CR in which we
will be exploring planet Earth and other
different planet States than ever before
we'll be exploring it so that's not all
we will also delve deeper into the world
of creativity by building an application
that would actually help you plant
different different kinds of plants and
into your room if we talk about the
fourth project that we are going to
build we are going to explore the
possibilities of e-commerce with that
application we're gonna create an
interior design application that would
actually help us put different different
Interiors different different sofas
chairs onto our room I am priyashi
co-founder and CTO fantern and I bring
you the three comprehensive augmented
reality course that is going to teach
you to develop augmented right
experiences with the AR foundation and
unity engine
so without any further Ado let's move
forward and learn how to build such
captivating and amazing augmented yet
experiences
hey everyone welcome to this lecture and
in this lecture we are actually going to
build our very first augmented reality
project with ar core and AR Foundation
from the very scratch I'm going to teach
you how you can set up the project how
you can uh build the AR Foundation app
to your devices right so without any
further Ado let's move forward and let's
learn what to do next okay the very
first thing you have to do is you have
to open your Unity up and you have to
create a new project now if you don't
have any Unity version installed you can
simply go to installs option click on
install editor choose the editor of your
choice now in this course I am going to
use Twitter what you want so you can
simply click on install then select the
Android build support because we are
actually going to bend for Android and
also select the iOS bit support and then
you can simply click on continue
accept the terms and condition and
simply click on it okay that's gonna
take a bit of time it's gonna of course
it's gonna take a lot of Internet like
around four or five GBS maybe so it's
gonna download the package it's gonna
install so given the time it needs okay
and once the project I mean the unity
editor has been installed what you can
do is you can simply go to the project
section now what you have to do is you
have to create a new project now it is
very simple to create a new project what
you have to do is you have to click on
this new project button and once you
have create like you know clicked on
that particular button you will be able
to find this option called editor
version now you you can choose any
editor you want for this course I'm
going to use
2021.3.50 F1 you can also go with any
other version such as new to 2019 or
2020 but I would suggest you to like you
know keep up with this video that is
used 2021 version of unity now once
we've selected the unity editor you will
be seeing there are multiple options for
templates right there's 2D there's 3D
there's 3D mobile 2D urp then sample urp
I think there's hdrp also then there's
like you know a lot of examples that
Unity has already coded for us that
Unity has already given us but for now
for this video we are gonna wait uh
gonna go with a blank project and we are
going to select 3D core because we want
to have the 3D functionalities now if
you want to build any sort of like you
know 2D game or anything
you can simply select the 2D code option
but for this video I'm gonna go with 3D
code as we are gonna need the 3D version
of that
once you have selected that 3D core
option what you have to do is you have
to change the project now you can change
the project name to anything I'm Gonna
Keep It planets AR you can also keep it
anything you want and you can also
change the location of the project if
you want okay and that simply click on
create project that's gonna start the
process and it's gonna create a project
for you okay
now once the project has been created
you will see this editor now this editor
is called Unity editor now within this
editor now what what we have to do is we
have to set up the project okay we have
to set up this single territor so that
it is able to build for Android devices
and it should be able to support
augmented reality okay
now
just clear out our head now okay just
clear out your head and listen to
now the very first process that you want
to go through is switching your platform
and setting up the project the reason is
you can see you can set up the project
later on also after importing the assets
doing everything but the reason why you
should set up your project at the very
first because let's say I have added
multiple Assets in the project folder
okay so what's gonna happen is let's say
I remove the graph Graphics API I switch
my build platform the switching part the
setting apart it's gonna take a much
longer time okay and definitely we don't
have that much time to wait for it to
build and switch the project and all the
process it needs to be done so that's
why that's why you should always set up
your project at the very first then only
import the required assets
so let's move forward the very first
thing you have to do is you have to
click on file go to build settings now
in the build settings you'll be able to
find multiple options in here like
there's Windows Mac Linux dedicated
server Android iOS PS4 PS5 now
now I want to build for Android devices
only so I'm going to select Android but
you can also build for iOS devices if
you want now there's one thing that you
have to keep in mind okay the code base
will be very much similar because we are
going to use AR Foundation now AR
Foundation makes it easier for the
developers to build for both IOS and
Android how it provides two plugins
called AR plugin and AR code XR
plugin now AR kit is supported on iOS
devices and AR core exam plugin is
supported on Android devices so if you
want to build for iOS you can simply
install AR it and if you want to build
for Android you can simply install AR
code exampler okay that's it nothing
much nothing too complicated but again
like you know if you want to use AR core
on iOS devices that's also possible you
just have to install the application
from the App Store I think it's called
as Google services for AR code or I
maybe it's called AR code I'm not really
short but there's a plugin for that so
you can you can simply install that uh
within your iOS device and simply like
you know work with it build the
applications in there and again if you
do this want to do the same for Android
that is built for AR code then make sure
your Android device supports the airport
okay there are uh there's a whole list
or where you can find if your device
supports VR code or not and if it does
what you can do is you can go to Play
Store and search for Google services for
here okay the link will be down below in
the description you can simply begin to
search for that app or you can go
through the link that will be given in
the description and simply install that
particular because without that uh the
AR code apps won't work on your Android
device
so I hope that's that's clear to you so
let's move forward now you have to
select this Android option and click on
switch platform now it's gonna take a
few minutes or few seconds depending on
your system to phrase the platform so
given the time it needs
bye
now once it has switched its platform to
Android the next thing you want to do is
we want to set up the project so that we
don't have to like you know go through
the whole painful built-in process again
and it shouldn't take much time for you
okay we want to make sure that now once
you like you know once you have switched
the platform you at the very like you
know bottom left you'll be able to find
this player setting so click on the
player settings
from there the very first thing you want
to change is the company name you can of
course you can keep it uh as a disk but
I would suggest to change the name right
keep it anything you want so for now I
want to keep it coded reality because
that's the name of my channel and then
there's uh I I'm just going to keep the
product name as planets here because
that's the most suitable way okay now if
you want to set uh any icon for the
application you can totally do that from
here now I uh in the assets folder I
already have a icon so I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you how you can do that now
after that uh in the resolution in
presentation you would want to uh go to
this default orientation option and make
sure to uh select the portrait option in
here because we don't want the landscape
left or landslip right or any other
option there we just want it to be in
portrait mode of course if you want you
can also keep it uh in landscape mode
but again you have to design the UI that
for now I'm gonna show you how you can
do the scene but for portrait
now once uh the orientation has been
selected the next thing you can do is
you can simply go to other settings now
from there make sure you uncheck this
autographics API now the reason why we
are unchecking this Auto Graphics API
because by default our Unity project
something called uh cut date something
called Volcan right now is another
Graphics API just like open GLE
but the problem is AR code doesn't
really support worker so if your project
already has Balkan and if you haven't
removed it AR code after building right
AR code is gonna give you a lot of
letters and your build won't complete so
we don't want the World Cup Graphics API
so I'm just going to select the welcome
from here and click on this minus now
that's going to remove the working API
from our project and once that has been
removed you can simply go to
multi-threader rendering and make sure
to uncheck this multi-threaded rendering
then I didn't go below and you'll be
able to find this option called Minima
API level now make sure to set to
Android 7.0 because AR code requires a
minimum bid level of Android 7.0 if you
go below that maybe
6.05.1 and maybe below that the problem
is that it won't build it's going to
give you error so you have to keep
either Android 7.0 as the menu APN level
or maybe above you can also keep 8.07.1
8.19 10 anything you want okay but just
not below Android 7.7 now work that has
been done you have to change your
scripting back into IL to CPP the reason
is AR code doesn't really support 32-bit
architecture anymore so you need to
build it for uh like you know 64-bit
architecture now to do that you you have
to set your scripting back into i2cp
because if you if we check out mono you
won't be able to find this arm 64 option
now to get this on 64 option you have to
shift to Il to CPT and make sure to
check this arm 64 option from there and
once that has been done we are actually
done for now with the player settings we
still have a few more settings to go
through but that will only be enabled
when AR foundation and er Port has been
installed
so to do that
simply close these window
go to window go to package manager then
again from the drop down select Unity
registry
now from there what you can do is
give it the time to load it might take a
bit of time depending on your internet
now it loaded uh very fast on my in my
case uh now once the package has been
loaded what you can do is you can search
for ER okay now once you search for AR
you'll be able to find this AR
Foundation AR code and arcade exam
plugin now these are the three packages
we need to focus on if you are building
for iOS I would highly suggest to go
with AR kit because uh I wouldn't
suggest to go with ar code is best with
Android so keep it for Android only and
if you want to build for iOS then go
with AR kit don't worry apart from the
building process everything is similar
you don't have to make any changes to
your code you don't have to make any
changes to your project setup just
whenever you are building you have to
set the project settings according to
iOS okay now for this course I'm gonna
use Android so I'm gonna simply install
the AR codex but before that you have to
install this AR foundation 4.2.7 so just
select this version and click click on
install
give it the time it teach for the
installation now once that would be done
we'll also be installing AR code example
now AR code is necessary to build AR
experiences for Android
me
now as you can see AR Foundation has
been installed the next thing you have
to do is you have to click on the exam
plugin and then click on install
now once both of these has been
installed what you can do is simply
close this window again click on file
build settings click on player settings
and then go to this particular option
exam plugin manager okay now in here you
will be able to find multiple options
that is AR code Oculus and Immunity mock
hmd now Oculus and unity mock hmd is not
something we want to mess with as of now
we wanna uh do everything with this AR
core option okay now this ER core option
is very important you must check it out
the reason is you can see in here you
you are able to see a text called
initialize its are on start now that
means whenever your you start your
application it's going to initialize the
particular plugin you have checked it so
for me I have just checked AR code so
it's going to initialize the AR code
plugin at the beginning of the starting
of the application
okay so it is mandatory for you to check
the AR core option if you don't do it
then ER or won't be initialized at a
start at the very start and you will be
you won't be able to use AR code within
your application so make sure to check
this option out and once it has been
checked you can simply close this window
and now we have got our project set up
very well okay now the next thing what
you have to do is you have to delete the
main camera okay once you have delete
the main camera
you have to right click in the hierarchy
click on XR add an ER session widget
then again add an AR session now ER
session origin would be responsible for
handling the camera the plane tracking
the image tracking the recasting and all
every and all the other things that are
necessary for performing augmented
reality and the ER session will be
controlling the whole life cycle of
unity and your AR application so both of
these components are mandatory and you
can see inside they are session audit we
also have an AR camera which will be uh
capturing all the real world scenario
and will be like and this whole AR
section origin will be helping you to
place the object into the real okay now
here you can see we have set up our
project properly we have set it up
properly and now what we have to do is
we have to import the assets okay but
before that let me change the name of
the scene okay so I'm Gonna Keep It uh
planets
let's follow it or maybe or maybe let's
uh call it home swing because we want a
whole speed which will help us to
navigate between different different uh
like you know planets that we have in
here now we are going to call this home
screen
and another one you have to create
another C we are going to call that CNS
Arc okay or let's do one thing as we
have already set it set this scene up
for uh augmented reality let's call this
scene as uh
planet
okay let's create another C that will be
having the default main camera and we
are going to call it home screen
now the uh the reason I removed this
main camera
the reason I removed this main camera is
because it renders the virtual scene
okay it actually renders this particular
scene so that's why I removed it the AR
camera would actually be rendering the
rear mode so that's why you have to add
the AR camera if you want to perform
augmentation but as this is the home
screen it doesn't needs any sort of
augmentation that's why we want to use
the main camera as the default camera
okay now once both of the scenes are
created we want to import the asset
okay and we simply wanna import the
Assets Now I already have if you if you
see here I already have a folder created
in where I am having all the unity
assets stored now this is the planet's
AR assets that we want to import
it's again fairly simple right click in
the project setting click on import
click on custom package I simply import
this planet CR Assets Now again you can
do the same by simply dragging and
dropping uh all the Assets in here
so both of the way works choose the one
you are comfortable
now once you have like you know dragged
and drop the or maybe imported the
package within your Unity screen you
will be able to find this particular
window now you you have to Simply click
on the import import option that we all
the textures all the files that are
included in the package will be imported
in your project file so give it the time
it needs
yeah now here you can see that we
imported our project now inside the
asset folder you will be able to find
textures then there's Planet textures
that will be containing all the like you
know textures for the planets then
there's UI texture that will be used for
our user interface uh here you can also
see that we got a logo now we will be
using this logo also that I also have a
model for the Saturn so we will be using
all these uh in our project to get
everything set it up okay
so once the assets have been imported
the next thing you want to do is
let's create the UI okay let's create
the user interface first then we are
going to move on to the then we are
actually going to move on
to our augmented realityc okay
so now once the home screen has been
created simply double click on it to
open it then what you have to do is you
have to right click in the hierarchy
click on the UI add a canvas okay now
the canvas is actually going to help us
to create UI for this whole scenario and
go to your game window and make sure to
change it to uh some portrait okay now I
actually already have some preloaded
templates from wyson now if you want you
can also do the same for yourself you
can like simply click if you if I show
you click on this uh option right and
you'll be able to find this plus sign if
you click on this plus sign you can name
the device you can add its width and
height okay that way you will be able to
get the proper mode or the proper device
you want to use now for me I'm gonna use
this OnePlus not C to light for myself
you can use any other UI you want if you
are let me select something in between
Maybe
yeah redmi note 9 seems much better so
I'm gonna go with redmi Note 9.
now here you can see that it's a blank
canvas okay and inside the canvas we
don't really have any and also also this
is a really good feature that we have in
unity
if you click on this 2D option you will
be going on to the 2D mode and once you
go on to a 2d mode you can double click
on this canvas object and you can zoom
out like you can bring the canvas to
your phone this is a very useful feature
that I think you should know about
you can simply click on the canvas
option then in the at the inspector
you'll be able to find this canvas
Scalia okay now in the canvas query you
will be able to find this UI scale mode
make sure to change it it is actually by
default set it up with the constant
pixel size we definitely don't want that
to make the UI responsive we want kill
with spaces okay so make sure this uh to
select the scale with screen size option
and once you have select that
in the canvas we want a background okay
we want a background so that not
everything this this whole like you know
weird looking background isn't visible
so the very better the the better way to
do is right click in the canvas you can
either like you know go to UI add a
panel in here right
or you can what you can do is you can
simply add an image okay we can also add
an image like go to UI add an image in
here and then
change the name of your image to
background
now once you have selected the image in
you can you might find this option
called direct transform in the inspector
if you select the image right and in
there you will be able to find a small
box right so click on that box press alt
in your keyboard if you are a Windows
and press option on your map
so once you click the alt button on
option button on your device
you can simply like you know at the very
bottom right you will be able to find
the stretch options simply click on that
stretch option and you can build and you
will be able to see that it has failed
the whole image in there okay it is
filled the whole background so we want
to keep it to white as of now and if we
go to our assets and go to the textures
option and click on UI textures you'll
be able to find this diagram okay now
what you can do is now basically the the
assets are already set to texture type
to like you know Sprite today and even
but let's say if you import some other
like you know import some external image
by yourself you will be able to see that
it will be set to this default option
okay now if it is set set to default
just change it to Sprite 2D anyway
because that's the option we are gonna
need
now once you have selected the
background make sure to drag and drop
this background image from the UI
texture in here you can see that we got
a pretty neat and clean background
uh for our UI now once you have selected
this particular background you can add
another image let's click on UI let's
add an image now this is going to be our
headache okay that is it is going to
contain that I tell for us so I'm simply
gonna drag and drop this home header and
click on set native size and now reduce
the size Mill 0.5 yeah 0.5 seems much
better and to Anchor this right without
anchary this uh like you know this
planet's AR logo won't really be
responsive so you have to Anchor it to
that to answer it simply click on the
heading
press alt in your keyboard open this
option anchor presets option in here
just simply press on the top that way
you will be able to set the like you
know this particular anchor to the very
now let's say if we change the
resolution or maybe change the UI you
can see that it is adapting to the
particular interface okay and that's
what we want now once you have added
this particular heading we are also have
to add a few buttons to navigate between
the planets right now again it's pretty
simple uh first of all I would like you
to let you know
create a empty container that way it
would be much better for us to like you
know handle all the uis I mean the UI
buttons let's name it uh button button
Handler
now what you can do is you can simply
like you know click on this button
Handler again press alt in your keyboard
and make sure to stretch it out to the
very top and you can like you know
reduce or maybe
change the top value by something 250
maybe yeah change it by uh change the
Top Value to 250 now what you can do is
you can keep on adding the buttons in
here okay and uh let's do it let's add
this button Handler let's click on this
button Handler add a UI let's add an
image in here
let's anchor this image to the top
and let's reposition this image maybe
let's let's change the weight and height
to maybe 200. that was seen much better
yeah totally much better and let's make
it to 200 okay and minus 100
now this looks diff uh this definitely
looks much better and let's still change
the image size name to baby or
okay
now
let's actually let's try minus 200 yeah
this looks much better let's duplicate
the button
and put it uh to maybe the site right
let's put it to the side like this and
change it to minus 200 and again minus
200 that way we got two different
buttons for our planets okay now you can
change it to maybe
Mars right uh similarly you can uh set
the C do the same thing for other
buttons right so for now I'm just gonna
keep these two buttons what you can do
is you can replicate uh much more
buttons in here like I already have
options for Jupiter Saturn Uranus Venus
and other planets too so you can
definitely do that for now let's keep
these two buttons only and the next
thing you have to do is you have to
select the Earth button drag and drop
this Earth texture in here and again
select the mask button and drag and drop
the masks option in here now definitely
it seems like the spacing is too much
let's increase the weight to mainly 400
um how about 350 yeah 350 seems much
much better and the next thing you can
do is as these are images right these
doesn't have the capability of button
now
what you can do is Select both the
images click on ADD component and add a
button component into onto these images
right now if you click on these uh
images the buttons like these will these
images will be clickable okay so you can
click on these images and set any
functionality you want for now now once
we got the Earth and Mars Butters of it
out we have to create a new UI okay so
not UI exactly but a new C so I'm going
to call this uh Planet seal to earth now
once I've opened this Earth C what I can
do is I can create a new spear okay
that's gonna Conte the
Earth planet so I'm going to reset its
transform set the Z value to 5 or maybe
how about two two seems much better I
mean let's keep it to four four would be
much like four would look much better
the next thing you want to do is rename
the spear to R
and then create a new material okay so
I'm gonna create a new folder called
material
now I'm gonna create a material called
Earth
so
and then simply drag and drop this Earth
material on top of that Earth object now
if you change the color you you will be
able to see that the object is also
changing the color according to the
material so that means our material has
been applied properly once the material
has been applied what you can do is you
can simply search for the Earth texture
texture now we already have this 2K
Earth Day map I'm gonna select that and
you can see that we actually got the
Earth texture in here now it might seem
that like you know it's a bit too flashy
uh you can definitely skim through the
shaders that we have you can search for
uh like you can simply click on this
drop down option search for unlit and
you can set it to texture that we will
be getting this option but it definitely
looks much more dull uh let's go for
legacy shaders let's try let's start
diffuse yeah this one looks much better
but I think uh the standard one look was
looking better so let's hear the
standard standard one only but if you
want to reduce the smoothness you can
definitely do that let's take two maybe
point four yeah point four seems much
better and now you can see that we got
our Earth properly
set it up now what you can do is we want
this Earth to rotate right because of
course Earth does rotate so you we have
to write a new script okay that script
would actually be helping us to rotate
the Earth
now again it's pretty simple so create a
new folder called scripts folder now
inside the script folder what we want to
do is we want to write a script that
should actually rotate the art on its
axis so I'm going to create a new script
let's name it rotation controller
okay
so let me edit the time to compile and
once it has compiled just open the
script in your IDE now I'm gonna I'm
using visual studio you can use Visual
Studio code Sublime Text on any ID you
are comfortable with
now once the script has been opened we
want to create a public variation called
public
uh
public game object
or object right let's call it or maybe
plan it off that would be much of a
universal need let's call it Planet
object
now once you have created this
particular variation you also have to
create another video byte other Vector 3
variable to be honest okay so let's
create a vector 3 variable public
website three
and then name it rotation Vector because
that would actually be helping us to
control in which axis we want to rotate
our Arc okay so rotation vector
now within the update function what you
want to do is you want to reference like
take a reference to the planet object
okay and pass the rotation Vector uh
within this particular parameter as a
parameter to the rotate function and
then multiply it with time dot there
okay that's going to give us a much more
realistic rotation bag
now if we compile the script and add
this script to the particular Earth and
drag and drop the Earth object as a
planet object and uh let's see let's
play it okay now right now you can see
the Earth is not moving so if you
increase the value of this one right it
will be how about 10 yeah 10 looks much
better so now what I can do is I can
replace the value to 10 and now if I
play it you can see that we are the
planet is actually moving right uh the
plant is actually rotating
now next well you can like you know
replicate the scene maybe duplicate the
scene Again by con you can like select
the simple C press Ctrl D that's simply
gonna duplicate the scene and rename it
to Mars okay open that mask and rename
the object to maybe
Mars and then what you can do is you can
click either create a new material or
again uh like you know duplicate this
material change the name to bars and
then select the mask texture and simply
drag and drop this texture in here now
if we see
replay it you can see the mass is also
rotating properly right now what's next
okay what's next if we open this
particular scene if we go to the home
screen and if we press on this
particular button
we must be able to like you know switch
between seeds right if you press on R
then we should open the Earth scene if
we press on Mark then we should open the
Marcy definitely right but it's not
doing it right
so what should we do now to perform that
we actually have to create a new script
that would actually help us to switch
between C okay so again it's pretty
simple create a new script and call it
scene controller okay
now this scene controller will actually
be having a method to switch between the
seats so open this particular scene
controller now you have to add a using a
direct app so using Unity engine
Dot
scene manage okay once you've added that
simply click you know create a new
function public void
switch
scenes
and make sure it takes a parameter or a
string parameter and let's name it seed
name
once you have created the parameter the
next thing what you have to do is you
have to uh
and give a second
click manager you have to reference the
scene manager and
click on load C right that is load the
load scene method and within that you
have to pass the shield okay that way
will be will actually be able to switch
between multiple scenes that we have so
next what you want to do is you can
simply drag and drop this script to
anywhere you want let's attach this
scene controller to the canvas that we
have or maybe
let's not add it to the canvas let's add
it to the button handle okay and the
next thing what you can do is you can
simply click on Earth and Mars
add the particular uh like you know go
to this on click option click on ADD
option and then simply drag and drop
this button and Handler in here then
click on this no function click on scene
controller and make sure to switch to
this switch scenes option now you can
keep the name of your scene download
and if I still lived in Mars I'm going
to change it to boss okay
now if we let's say if we try to like
you know switch between the scenes
you can see that it is giving us
internet Earth and Mars is not loaded
that it couldn't be loaded so what you
can do is you can simply click on file
build setting click on ADD open scenes
just gonna add the home screen in here
then go to your series option at the
bars and Earth okay now if you like you
know
play this option
you can simply click on R and you can
see that it has loaded the over C but
again there are no options for going
back right we also have to add the
option to go back to the home screen
again you have to do the things the same
way it's pretty simple okay it's not too
hard so click on right click on the
hierarchy
create a new canvas
change its UI scale mode to scale with
screen size
uh then what you can do is you can
simply add an image now this image would
be acting as a button right so I'm going
to add the back texture in here
so you guys see I added the back button
texture I'm gonna click on set native
size and reduce the size to maybe
0.2
let's see how does it do not point to
decently not pointing maybe 0.5
so Pi 0.5 would be two big list go for
points F1 phone seems much better and
then click on the select transform fill
in the anchor preset
press alt on your keyboard and Anchor It
To The Top okay
that way you'll be getting this
particular button and you can be
how about we keep it 160 and
minus 100b so that way we got the button
in here
now again what you can do is you can
simply add a button component
you can add the particular script in
here that is history uh scene controller
script to the canvas
click on this click add an option to the
on click function drag and drop this
canvas in here
then click on scene controller click on
switch scenes and give the name of your
scene where you want to switch
now again
what you can do is you can simply copy
this too right make sure to copy the
canvas and the event system without the
event system your clicks won't be
registered
now you can go to the mass scene add
these two in here and just check if
everything's fine so you can see that
everything is loaded as it as it should
be now if you play this
you can see that we are able to navigate
back and forth between the seats
now this is it for this lecture okay we
actually needed a fully functional ER
application and I'll be adding a small
demo to this application at the very end
of the video okay so make sure to watch
that demo also and the task for this
okay the task for this lecture would be
to add a few more planets up in the list
and also you can add an information
panel that would actually be so showing
the information about these plan
properly okay so these are the tasks
these are the modifications that you can
do to this project and to build this
project what you can do is you can
simply click on file
click on build settings make sure all
the scenes are added up in here and then
click on build give the name to your
application I'm gonna click uh name it
build and also also before building a
forward to showing if you click on
player settings you can actually set
your icon now I already have a icon for
this so I'm gonna click on this select
option
go and look out for the icon it should
be somewhere here I guess I named it
logo so here you can see that we got the
planet CR logo now if you build the
application
you should be able when you like after
building the application if you install
the application on your device you will
be able to see the application with this
particular Loop so I'm simply gonna name
this application and build and I'm
simply gonna save the build okay so it's
gonna take a few minutes to build the
application for you
so yeah this is it for this lecture and
make sure you try to add a lot more
features to this application believe me
it's gonna be fun
hey everyone welcome to this lecture and
in this lecture I'm going to teach you
how you can build an augmented
reality-based simulation of a jet
turbine sounds amazing right so so let's
get started why wait
for the very first three you have to do
is to set up this project now to set up
this project you have to like you know
create a project first so to do that
what you can do is you can open your
Unity Hub click on this new project
option choose the unity editor version
you want to now for this course for this
lecture I'm going to use 2021 you can
also go for any other version like I
have to give it to
2020.3.4 tf1 also so you can go for any
other version you want but I would
suggest to like you know keep up with
2021 as it has the latest version latest
stable version that we have right now
and uh so yeah let's move forward now
once you have selected your editor
version right the next thing you got to
do is you have to select the template
now of course there are multiplicity of
places 2D template 3D template 2D urp 3D
mobile then 3D urp 3D sample c new RPM
like you know many other templates uh
that you can down but for this now we
want to start with a black 3D template
so we are going to select the second
option that is 3D code now once you have
selected that particular option you have
to name your product
now what should you name you can name
anything right I can I can name it jet
turbine
simulation right I can I can name it
this way then if you want to change the
location of your project you can totally
do that you just have to select this
location option click on it once and
then what you can do is you can simply
select the folder you wanna create the
project
and once all these things have been done
you can simply create project now if you
don't have any Unity editors what you
can do is you can simply go to install
click on install editor select the unity
version so this is the latest version
that is out there that is 2080 1.3.17 F1
what you can do is you can simply click
on install
Ed the Android build support because if
you want to build for Android you are
going to delete it and if you want to
bid for iOS you can select that
and then click on continue uh agree the
license and then click on next okay and
then it would start downloading and
installing the editor and all the
packages that is necessary for building
for Android and iOS device
and then you can again like you know
create the project give it a few minutes
to like you know create the project and
then we can get started now once you
have created the project
this particular editor window will be
opening up right this is the unity
editor window and in here we have to the
very first thing we have to do is we
have to set up this project so that we
can build for Android and it should also
support augmented reality
now you already know for all these four
projects that we are going to develop we
are going to use uh something called AR
foundation and we are
so AR Foundation is a pool of like a
universal package in where you can add
the ER kit and AR code plugin that would
actually help you uh build
cross-platform AR applications
so now before setting up all of that
okay what you have to do is you have to
click on file click on build settings
and then switch to the Android minute if
you are building for Android or if you
are building for iOS you can simply
switch to the ions okay but for now we
want to keep it to Android only so what
we are going to do is we are gonna
select the Android build and then click
on switch platform now this is a small
tip that I always follow basically what
happens now if if there are already
assets available within your editor
window that is within your project
itself it's going to take a lot more
time to set up this whole project okay
because it's gonna convert all the
materials all the assets to the like you
know related versions and to avoid that
kind of like you know time what we want
to do is we want to switch to the
platform setup everything at the very
first before importing all the assets
that we have okay so that's what I do
always and believe me that saves me a
lot of so I would recommend you guys to
do that
now once you once your platform has been
switched the next thing you can do is
you can simply click on player settings
now from player settings you can change
the company name I'm Gonna Change it to
coded reality
okay because that is my channel snake
then you can change the product name to
maybe jet turbine
and then if you if you have any sort of
icons for your application you can like
you know add the icon to the folder and
then select it in here that way you can
also like you know add a logo for your
application
and once all these have been done you
have to go to your resolution and
presentation now we want this app to be
in landscape mode okay so for that what
we are going to do is we are gonna uh go
to this default orientation and I wanna
check out landscape left okay once you
have selected landscape left what you
have to do is you have to click on and
get other settings make sure to uncheck
this Auto Graphics API because we want
to remove this Balkan API from here okay
because uh ER Port doesn't really
support Vulcan so we have to remove that
orderly or else you will be like you
know getting errors while building the
application so we are simply going to
remove that Vulcan API once that has
visible what you can do is you can turn
off this multi 3D rendering as we are
not gonna need it and then go directly
below to this minimum API level and set
it to Android 7.0 because that is the
minimum API level that ER core actually
supports
uh if you if you are choosing any
version below that you are gonna face in
so make sure to uh like you know keep it
7.0 or above seven points
okay and then we're gonna have to shift
our scripting back into IL to CPP okay
now once we shift the scripting back
into iot CPP you can check this arm 64.
the reason we are doing this is the AR
code doesn't really supports 32-bit
architecture it only supports uh 64-bit
architecture so you have to shift
towards 64 architecture and with mono
that's not really possible like if you
check more load you won't be able to uh
you won't be having this option for arm
64. so to get that arm 64 option you
have to switch towards IL to CPP and uh
here's another I'll to CPP builds are
much more optimized and much more faster
in terms of loading I like the CPP
builds are much more faster and much
better and much optimized than mono
built so whenever like you know you are
deploying your app to production make
sure to do it in il to CPP scripting
back okay and once you are done with
this
the next thing you have to do is you
have to install the plugin you have to
install the AR Foundation plugin and
also you have to install
the AR code example
and if you are on iOS then you have to
install AR kit plug and also here's
another thing AR core is also supported
on iOS devices okay so if you wanna like
you know stay up with ar core only what
you can do is you can simply like you
know
install AR code plugin and also uh
install the AR code from uh Apple's App
Store okay that way you'll be able to
run ER code on iOS devices also but I
think it's much better to like you know
use ER Kit only because arkit has much
more functionality to be honest like
body tracking that uh AR code doesn't
have why Always if you if you are on iOS
right always try to use AR kit as much
as possible rather than using Yahoo and
if you are using Android then definitely
your code is the V2 now to set up this
project for augmented reality you have
to click on window then click on package
manager from there uh you'll be able to
find this particular drop down right and
the talk so you have to click on that
drop down and select with unity registry
so give it the time to load right and
once it loads the packages you will be
able to find a lot of options in here
you know like it's confusing I
understand that but to sort everything
out just search for AR right with ar you
are going to find a lot of different
packages now for this tutorial we're
gonna need a
and if you are choosing to install AR
kit plugin also there won't be much
difference in building like you know
setting up the project the Kodi part but
yeah the uh the building part will be
different the deploying part will be
different for AR kit so I'm gonna stick
with ar code and AR Foundation I'm gonna
click on AR Foundation the version I'm
gonna use is 4.2.7 as this is a stable
version and simply gonna click install
give it the time to install the packages
give it the time to install the air
Foundation packages and once it is done
what you can do is you can also install
the AR code XR plug
now as you can see we already installed
the AR Foundation package the next thing
we have to install is AR code example so
I'm going to Simply install it
add do you know the benefit of using AR
Foundation AR Foundation helps us to
like include both AR core and AR kit
plugin so with a single code base you
can build for both the platforms it
brings a more cross-platform
functionality for AR so I really like
using AR foundation and AR tool other
than using any other SDK that is out
now once I have installed both the
packages right you have to go to your
player settings again and make sure that
AR core gets initialized uh whenever it
is built first so what you have to do is
you have to click on player settings
then simply go to EXA plugin management
and make sure to check this plugin
provide okay if you if you don't check
this AR core uh like you know AR code
option in the plugin providers the AR
core part won't be initialized when you
start the application which is
definitely not the thing we want we want
uh AR code to initialized whenever the
app is started app has been started so
we want to check this particular option
and then what you can do is you can
rename your scene I'm gonna rename my
screen to Jet byte okay
and once I renew the seat you can see
that we we got the c d m as jet turbine
at the very top and also before setting
up the scene I just want to make sure
that all the settings in the player
settings are totally fine so let me go
through that once uh yeah we got the
graphics EPA sorted we got a
multi-threaded rendering sorted out
we've also got the minimum API level
sorted out
we got the scripting back end and the
arm 64 option sorted up now there's one
more thing if you want to uncheck this
on V7 option the 32-bit option you can
do that let me keep it for now but if
you want you can also unchain that
and uh yeah everything seems fine and in
the exam plugin management also we got
the AR code plugin provider check uh so
we got everything set up uh like for our
project so that it supports AR now so
that our scene also supports here we
have to delete the main cap because this
camera is the virtual camera and it only
records the C only give this game view
right we want the real world so that we
want the AR app to access our camera and
then like you know place the objects
there so to do that AR Foundation has
something called uh
AR session origin so what you can do is
you can simply right click in the
hierarchy click on XR add an AR session
origin and then again click on Exon add
an ER session now definitely you already
know what the serious session object
does it basically handles uh all the
like you know camera and all the plane
management and everything that is out
there all the functionalities and this
AR session actually handles the whole
life cycle of augmented reality and
unity so it is mandatory to have both of
these components in here now once you
have these components what you have to
do is
just create a few folders the first
folder I want to create is called the
script folder okay because that is this
particular folder is very necessary
other than that we want to create a
prefabs folder in case we need it and
then we also want to create a materials
for okay in case reading now I already
have packaged the assets for you guys
okay it's already packaged in a Unity
package so what you have to do is you
have SIM you simply have to download
that package from the link given below
and once you download that particular
package you have to import it the
process is very simple once you download
it you can see that I have this folder
called Unity Assets Now what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna either I can simply drag
and drop this folder in here right or I
can do I can simply click on import
package select the custom package go to
the location of the folder and simply
open it that way you can see that we got
a lot of options in here you don't have
to like you know get confused between
these options
what you just have to do is you have to
click on you okay once these packages
packages are important
he will see an assets folder now within
that asset folder there is an audio file
another one is this jet engine folder
which contains the prefab for the jet
engine now what you have to do is you
have to Simply drag and drop this jet
engine in this particular hierarchy and
you will be able to see that this
particular J engine has been positioned
correctly now this is the preferred
position this is the position I tested
out this application with so that's why
I've kept this position if you want to
change it like if you want to move it a
bit more forward what you can do is you
can simply uh you know use this anchor
to move this thing uh much more far
further from the camera for now I would
just want to keep it to 2 as it is much
more of a preference and then I have
made the rotation to 90 okay you can
also keep it that way but I would
suggest to keep it true 90 or maybe uh
one eight okay if you want to see the
front view of uh front view directly
from the cap but for now I just want to
keep it to nine that way I'll be able to
get the product
okay and now here you can see that we
got our like you know project attempt we
got the check turbine India what about
the functionalities we need to code
something we just don't want to augment
this it's pretty simple we just don't
want to augment this thing
what do we want to do is just a
secondary just a second here you can see
that this ER session origin is at the
top right so we don't want it at the two
top we want it at the center so what you
can do is you can simply click on this
transform like click on this particular
session go to the inspector and in this
transform you will be able to find this
three dots click on that acceptably
reset the drop now I will be able to see
the object and the game object in here
let our bind in
okay let's talk about the functionality
now within this app we want some Intel
activity or is this app will be boring
right this is more of an educational
application which is going to teach
people about a jet turbine so how should
we do this now the basic mechanism that
I'm going to teach you today is to like
you know you can disable the some part
of this particular model like let's say
if I wanna see the internal parts of
this particular like you know this jet
turbine what I can do is I can simply
disable this Hull to see what is exactly
inside this particular jet turbine and
if I want I can also enable it okay that
way we'll be able to get a much more
broader view much better view of this
particular uh Jet top okay so to do that
it's it's actually pretty simple okay
but before getting to that mechanism I
want this particular like you know jet
turbine that is this particular what is
that oh rotor or blades I want this
blades to rotate
okay so to do that I'm just going to
write a very simple script okay so I'm
gonna what you have to do is go to the
script folder right click click on
Create and create a new C sharp you can
call this script as uh rotation
controller you can name it anything I'm
just gonna name it rotation controller
as it sounds much better
now let the script compile and once the
script has been compiled just open it
within your Visual Studio or any other
editor that you are using I am using
visual studio for now so I'm simply
going to use that one so give it the tag
okay now here you can see that we got
the start and update method so let's
remove all of these okay we are going to
need the update method but before that
let's create a variable now we are going
to create a public vector3 variable now
you will see why I'm why I am exactly
creating a vector 3 video pretty soon so
given the type
okay once you have created this
particular Vector 3 variable you have to
go to the update method then what you
have to do is you have to write
transform to rotate to rotate
and inside that you'll have to pass this
rotation vector and then multiply it
with time dot Delta okay so that way
you'll be able to rotate your rotational
Motors okay that is these bleeds
so let's give it the time to load yeah
so as you can see once we got this
particular script loaded up compiled
what you can do is you can search for
the turbine and then that is this you
know bleed let me show you it should
rotate you know something like this so
to do that what you're going to do is
you can simply like you know first of
all select the turbine option once I
have selected that just simply add this
rotation script in there and that maybe
change the Y value let's say uh in which
axis is it rotating so it is rotating in
the y axis 1 gonna simply change it to
maybe a hundred okay and once I have
changed the value to 100 you can uh I
cannot check if it is rotating by
playing the scene
so let's see as you can see that yeah we
are able to rotate the particular
jet turbine
in a certain direction okay so our
jitterbahn is rotating it seems more
realistic now let's add the other
functionality that is enabling and
disabling the objects in here okay and
before we do that we are going to create
a simple UI so what you have to do is
you have to again go to the hierarchy
right click up in there
uh go to the UI option
then search for this canvas okay now
canvas would actually help us to create
the UI now I'm gonna shift to a much
better landscape view I'm going to use
this particular one plus not C to light
uh device resolution this is the device
that I am using for testing so I'm going
to use this resolution for now if you
want you can also like you know try to
find some resolution of the devices that
you want to add and simply click on this
add option give give its name and then
with that height
that way you will be able to create all
these options that I have created for
myself
so let's revert that and here you can
see that we got the canvas option
now in here you'll be able to find
something called uh canvas scalar from
there you'll be able to find this UI
scale mode make sure to change it to uh
scale with screen size once you have
changed it
this would actually help you to read the
UI much more responsive now once you
have changed the canvascaler option
create a button okay so I'm gonna create
a button text mesh Pro now if you are
creating a text message Pro button it
should prompt uh a tmb importer simply
click on import TMP Essentials
give it the time to load
once that particular thing has been
loaded
just edit the button once right just uh
see if you can like
resize it a bit just for uh you know
make it to look much more paid up much
more you know better so I'm just gonna
do it this way yeah this one looks much
better
let me Center it right so I did Center
it now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
maybe reduce the scale a bit maybe
um Point size yeah 0.5 looks much better
so let's change it to okay let's change
it to point a yeah uh this is much more
visible
he appoints it much is much more visible
and then what you have to do simply
click on this uh transform option from
there press alt in your key okay if you
are on a Windows PC press alt and if you
are on a Mac I think option is for an
alternative for at all so you have to
click on option and then you have to
select this particular option so that it
anchors to the bottom
all right okay now once it has been
anchored what you can do is you can
maybe like increase the position of it
maybe let's see yeah this looks much
much more cleaner and let's name this
button as Hall okay
uh let's copy the name and again do the
C add this same for the text and make it
a bit bold yeah this now this particular
button looks much more clean right
doesn't it it definitely looks much more
cleaner if you want you can also create
a much like you know much better button
through figma or maybe some other UI
designing I'm gonna use the default one
that unit is providing now I'm going to
duplicate that particular button right
and let's uh let's see what else do we
have we have
we have the tubes okay we definitely
want to disable and enable the cube so
I'm gonna give it two
okay so we got the tubes in here
now
again go change the text of it to cubes
and then here's a pretty neat trick that
I really like just uh add this to maybe
one to eighty maybe 100 and then it this
this value actually depends on the UI so
I'm gonna add it as 110
now I'm again gonna duplicate it right
let's uh see what else could we add
um we had something called grid yeah we
got the grid now I'm also gonna change
the name to create
then
again minus 110
and then again change the text to grid
yeah
so once every is an uh text to grid I
also add another button for the Piston
so I'm gonna simply duplicate it name
this button paste turns
uh copy this again go to the text
change the text to past tense then
select the button again
uh add 110 there and you can see that we
got all the buttons positioned properly
okay now if we let's say
change the UI to something else you can
see that uh it is pretty much responsive
and it is you know working flawlessly as
it should
now once these buttons are added okay
what you have to do is you have to like
make sure that once you click this
button it should disable add enable the
objects that we have
to do that we have to create a script so
right click in the project folder that
is the scripts then click on Create and
create a new script let's call it mesh
okay this second mesh
problems
once you have created the scriptlet
compile okay so the script is compiled I
have opened it the very first thing you
have to do is you have to create a
variable called uh game object and name
it you know naming a variable is really
hard for me it takes a lot of time okay
let's name it turbine object
okay and once you have like you know
added this particular variable the next
thing you have to do is you have to
create a Boolean back okay let's keep it
private for now so private uh Boolean
and let's name it is active now of
course at the very first of the start of
the application all of the objects will
be active so we want to set it to true
and within the like you know
within this particular script you also
want to create another function that is
that will actually help us like if we
call that function it is going to help
us to disable and enable the object so
to do that I'm going to create a public
void that is public function
public
void Let's uh call it uh toggle
now once you write this function what
you have to do is
you have to check if the phone if the
like you know mesh is active or not now
we want to check this through this is
active Boolean so if
is active what you want to do is you
want to set the turbine object to false
so turbine object dot set active to
solve and also change the value of is
active Okay that way uh we will make
sure that uh like you know we are
getting the exact value or able to
switch on and off the uh the objects
now you have to add an else block now
within that is block you have to you
know again do the same but in this block
you have to turn the object active right
that is you have to make sure that
objects are true they are the objects
are actually on
so yeah this says that this this is the
whole script this is this new text is
actually going to help us toggle between
the objects so once you have saved the
script simply low let's load it now as
you can see that we got the script
loaded up now the next thing you have to
do is you have to select the objects you
wanna you know disable and enable so I'm
gonna select the hull then I'm gonna
select the tubes
then the Piston then the grids okay now
I'm simply gonna I'm simply gonna drag
and drop this mesh toggle option in here
then in the Highlander simply going to
drag and drop this file object then in
the tubes I'm gonna like add this tubes
then in the Pistons I'm gonna set this
this object to piston then in the grid
I'm gonna do the same for the okay once
you have done all of that select the
buttons
uh go down below to the on click make
sure to click on ADD and first of all
try adding one okay change uh the next
thing you have to do is you have to
select the first button
uh you can see right once the hull
object has been selected if you click on
the no function drop down you'll be able
to see something called this mesh toggle
okay this is the name of our script and
if okay if your or if your method right
if you are this particular function is
public you should be able to see that
function in here so I have this toggle
function I'm simply going to click on
the stable function and let's try this
particular you know option up right
let's see if it is enabling or disable
information
so if you click the button you can see
that it is enabling and disabling the
mesh now the next thing you want to do
is we want to do this all of the same
thing that we have done till now for the
other buttons also so I'm going to
select the tube then search for the
tubes option drag and drop it in here
select the mesh Toggler select toggle
then again same for Z I'm gonna search
for the grid option in here
install your token and again same for
the pistol
so as you can see now if we play it
you can see we can enable the hull we
can enable and disable the tube we can
enable or disable the grids we can also
enable and disable the Pistons we have
okay so this is it for this now
now of course after you have built this
whole application you want to test it
out right so how to do that again it's
pretty simple you have to click on file
click on build setting now you can see
that we have the scene active we have
the jet turbine scene active now there
are two ways to add a scene one you can
do is you can simply drag and drop this
scene in here and the way is that you
can click on ADD openc now this is gonna
add the active scene in here that is the
scene that is opened up within your
editor so it right now I have the jet
turbine scene open so it has added the
objective and seen in here
and once you have added the C you you
can either click build and run now the
build and run option will only work if
your phone has developer options turned
on and also it is connected to your
device
another one would be uh the build option
okay you can simply click on build name
the application anything fun for the
name it jet turbine and then click on
save that way your application will
start building and you can test your
application the way you want okay
another thing you have to keep in mind
is that if you want to test your
application make sure uh the Google
services for AR is installed within your
applic within your phone you can simply
search it on the Play Store and also
make sure your device is supported okay
that is it supports AR because a lot of
the device does not support VR also if
if your device does not support your
code that that means you won't be able
to run this application so make sure to
check that out
and once you have done all that your
build application you have you can
simply install it and test the
application out by yourself now at the
end of this video I'm gonna add a clip
that will actually show you the demo of
the particular application okay
so in this lecture we are actually going
to build an augmented reality
application that would actually help us
plant multiple different plants on our
surrounding area all right and to do
that we are going to use some specific
features such as raycast and uh AR plane
managers
so without any further Ado Let's uh move
forward and to get started with the
project I want you guys to create a new
project with unity engine I'm using the
same version that I was using in the
previous project so I would suggest you
to go with that same version
so right now what we have to do is we
have to integrate their foundation and
AR code package and I already know you
guys already know it but let me show you
how you can do that again
so first of all you had to go to the
package manager then you have to uh like
from the package you have to select this
Unity registry once you've selected that
you have to search for AR Foundation
and then simply uh install this AR
Foundation version and the version I'm
using at 4.2.7
okay so now that we have installed the
AR Foundation plugin what we have to do
is we have to also install the AR code
plug
then simply going to search for the AR
code plugin in here and simply install
it
so now that you have installed the
arcoexal plugin what you have to do is
you have to set up your project so that
you are able to build it for your
Android devices so go to file click on
build settings which are platform to
Android
now once you've switched your platform
to Android you have to go to player
settings and from resolution and
presentation I would want you guys to
change your default orientation to
Portrait you can also keep it to auto
rotation if you feel so but after that
you have to remove this check mark from
autographics API and remove the Vulcan
API as it is not supported by our code
we also have to turn off multi
threadrant rendering and also change the
minimum API level to Android
7 4.0 once you have done that you have
to change the scripting back into i2cpp
so that it supports 64 architecture
because AR core doesn't really builds
for a 32-bit architecture and it may
cause you a lot of error and once you
have changed your scripting backends
what you have to do is you have to put
away the plugin management and make sure
to enable AR code plugin provider once
you have done all of these
delete the main camera from your scene
then click on exact add an air session
origin and then again add and AR session
now once both of these are added select
the IR session origin add two components
arraycast manager
and then
The Ark in manager
now the AR recast manager would actually
help us throw raise uh two different
different uh like the planes that would
be generated in real time and the AR
plane manager would actually help us to
generate those planes those artificial
planes on top of the ground okay by
detecting the graph so now let's
uh
now all there is setups are done right
now the next thing what we have to do is
we have to import the Assets Now I
already have the assets written so I'm
simply going to click on import package
custom package then select this garden
plants asset and simply import it
thank you
now once the assets have been imported
what you have to do is you have to
create a few more folder one would be
for the scripts now I'm going to create
another folder for a material okay so
I'm going to show you what exactly I'm
creating that folder for and what we
have to do in there so once the
materials uh just again so once the
material folder is created create a new
material called uh
clean material okay so I'm gonna call it
plain transparent
mat okay and do one thing once you've
selected This Plane material
go to rendering mode and change it to
transparent and once you have done that
go to the Albedo section from there you
have this Alpha Channel decrease it down
to zero that way you will have a fully
transparent material on your hand and
once those things have been done also
you can try like you know reducing the
smoothness and once all of these are
done what you can do is you can simply
go to the hierarchy right click in here
select inksar and then add an AR default
layer now make sure to prefab this AR
default pin but before that what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna simply select this
materials option in here and drag and
drop this material options into the
element 0. I mean the plane material
into the elements once that has been
done you have to create another folder
called prefabs
and then you have to drag and drop this
AR default plane and delete it from the
hierarchy and then select the ER session
origin again and simply drag and drop
this clean prefab this AR default plane
into the plane prefab holder that is
available in the play and match now the
reason I did this because you will be
able to visualize the planes that are
being generated okay so the place would
be transparent with a black border you
can totally see that in the demo at the
very end of the video so whenever
whenever you will be trying to scan your
ground multiple different planes will be
generated and those planes will have
this transpend material okay that will
actually help you to visualize that yeah
there are
planes that are being generated and
that's where if you shoot the recast
it should disable the plane and also
place the plants okay and we are going
to implement that mechanism right now
now let me like make you go through the
prefab once that contains all the
plant model so if you go to assets
you will find this folder called models
from there there this folder got plans
and in here you'll be able to find this
prefab now I think there are in total 12
uh plants that are totally available
yeah there are total 12 plants that are
available now the next thing you have to
do is you have to write the script so
that it can hold those plants and
randomly Place those plants onto the
floor
so what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
go to a scripts folder create a new
script and let's call it
plant
placement
manager
once the script is straightened give it
some time to compile
once the script has compiled what you
can do is you can simply open the script
in your editor now I'm using visual
studio code for this
you can use Visual Studio ID too and any
other ID that supports unit Engine Okay
so
let's understand what do we have to do
in the script
before that let's understand what
exactly are we gonna Implement now the
basic implementation would be after the
ground planes are detected right after
the grounds are detected and the planes
are placed in there whenever I tap on
the screen it should place
uh the plants in that particular
position okay now of course to make this
happen there are multiple components we
have to work with we have to work with
the recast manager we have to work with
the plane manager and we also have to
work with the session origin and along
with that we also have to store all the
hits right whenever you tap on the
spleet it should be like it would be
registered as a hit so whenever the hit
happens
it should store those uh like positions
in there okay so let's uh implement this
whole script
so the very first thing is we have to
create a placeholder that would actually
held all those uh particular plant
models and yes so to do that you have to
write a public variable uh
and you have to give it the data type of
game object now it should be an added
because we want to store multiple
objects and I'm gonna call this variable
as flowers okay because it will be story
all the flowers that are in there now
save this
and then go to a unit engine
add this particular script to your AR
session origin and make sure to add all
the plants that are already available
okay so I'm gonna go to the prefab and
the easiest way to do is to little drag
and drop whole like you know plant
objects directly in that particular
uh array so before doing that what I'm
going to do is in the inspector menu at
the right of it you will be able to see
this lock option so just click on it now
if you select any of these models or you
can say prefab it won't really change
the inspector Mini
and what you can do is you can select
all of these models right here
and once you've selected those you can
directly drag and drop it inside this
particular script and you can see we got
all the 12 elements so you can say 12
plants directly inside this
particular
placeholder that we created as an array
now what you're going to do is you can
again unlock all of these so that you
don't have uh you know it doesn't get
stuck to that property now once you have
done that go back to the script again
now once you've opened the script you
have to reference the plane manager that
we have in here okay we have to
reference the plane manager we have to
reference the recast manager and also
the AR session voyage
so to do that what you have to do is you
have to write three more public
variables that would contain public
AR session origin
okay also I forgot before this you have
to include two different namespaces
because uh it contains all the necessary
functions for air Foundation to be able
to script okay so to do that you can
simply write using
Unity engine
dot AR Foundation
just a second
AR foundation and then you also have to
add more ring unit engine
dot exact
dot AR subsystem okay so they uh these
two files that is these two namespaces
contains all the important uh
functionalities that we need here
Foundation to provide us okay so for
example this we have to create a new
variable and we have to call it AR
session origin okay and we have to limit
session origin now this AR session
origin component is a part of this AR
Foundation names okay similarly you have
to create another variable and we have
to call it AR recast
manager and I'm gonna name this variable
as recast manager and I'm gonna create
another script called
ER plane manager because we will be
doing a few like you know tasks with the
planes that's why we are gonna need the
AR plan manager okay so I'm gonna name
it plain manager once these variables
are set up to what you can do is you can
simply go to your unit engine
and then from there drag and drop the AR
session origin Windows component again
drag and drop the array cast manager add
also the clean manager okay once these
managers have been added in here the
next thing you have to do is
you have to write an uh you actually
have to create a list that would contain
all the head positions right all the
raycast it's that have been done now I
will tell you what exactly is the
significance of that but for now let's
play in that particular list so you have
to make it private
private
list it should be of type AR recast hit
it
and then also name it I'm gonna name it
recast hits and then I'm gonna create a
new object of it so new
list array casted and
we have created or you can say
initialized our list in this particular
scenario in this particular script now
we also have to write an update
condition okay or you can say update
group in which we have to check for if
the person has tapped on the screen or
not okay so to do that what you have to
do is you have to write this update
function in here
once this update function is in place
you have to check if the person has
touched the screen or not so to check
that what you can do is you have to
write this if condition if
input dot get touched
okay and then you have to uh set the
parameter of the touch index to 0 and
then face equals equals touch phase dot
bigger okay this means that if you have
touched the screen or not okay and if
you have touched the speed the next
thing we want to do is we want to shoot
a request okay we gonna shoot array cast
and once the request has been shot we
want to place
the objects right random we want to
randomly place the objects
randomly
and then at the variant what we want to
do is we wanna uh disable the plane
manager and also we wanna remove all the
planes or you can say disable on the
planes that have been generated okay so
that the planes don't really become a
blockage to our views so we wanna what
we want to do is we wanna disable
the planes
and the plane manager
and the reason why we want to disable
the plane manager is because we want we
don't want the planes to be generated uh
generated all over again okay once they
have been designed so that's why now
let's get to the first part we want to
shoot the request right so what we have
to do is you we have to uh like you know
reference the recast manager so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to reference the
request manager as request manager then
I'm gonna click on like you know put the
dot and ask for the recast function
inside that raycast function you have to
pass this input dot mouse position okay
now Mouse position in your Android
device would actually result in the
position of your screen where you have
touched right if I am touching at a
certain position of your of my screen
it will return that particular position
within this particular function okay and
once the mouth position administrative
actually uh I did something wrong in
here okay I what I did was I gave this
parenthesis India and then a zero in it
you don't have to do that okay and once
this input Mouse position input.mouth
position is there the next thing what
you have to do is you have to pass the
recast hits uh list that we just created
okay now actually the raycast hit
contains all the position of the like
you know raycast that has been shot so
we need this weight cast list and we
want to store all the like whenever we
are touching right yeah whenever our
touch has happened it is shooting a
recast so we need to store that recast
into a certain uh variable or you can
say into a certain list right because we
want to access that recast hit because
it will be giving us the position and
whenever we touch right at wherever
position we are touching we want the
plant to be placed in that position so
recast hit is actually gonna return us
those position okay so we are gonna need
the recast hits and then what we have to
do is here to set the trackable type
group plane
with uh polygons within more molecule
okay and once this has been done
terminate the statement with an
semicolon now this is going to return a
Boolean value okay this is actually
going to return us a Boolean value
now as this function as this stripped or
you can say statement we wrote is going
to return a symbolian value what we have
to do is we have to store it in a
variable Boolean variable so I'm going
to call it a collision variable right so
whenever this particular Collision
Boolean is true what we want to do is we
want to place those objects if we want
to place those objects on our ground
if Collision
name object I'm going to call this as
object you can also call it as a flower
I am going to instantiate that
particular out okay instantiate
flowers now take the index of the
flowers and now what we want to do is we
want to generate a random number from 0
to the like you know n minus 1 that is
the length minus 1 so that we are able
to get all the flowers from that
scenario so
random dot range
0 comma
flowers
dot length minus 1.
so that way we'll be able to get all the
flowers randomly and we'll be able to
instantiate them and once these flowers
like you know have been instantiated
what we want to do is we want to set
their position to where we have actually
tapped so to do that object dot
transform dot position
equals raycast hits
zero Dot
uh pause
dot position okay so this is why we are
actually why we have actually created
that list called recast head because it
actually stores the position of the
raycast that has been shot onto the
ground and that is how we are actually
going to place those objects so I hope
this particular topic about uh recast
hits is pretty much clear now the next
thing we want to do is now basically we
uh the script that we created this would
be enough for this experience to work
but the problem with that will will be
is that we are generating those planes
right so it has some material so it will
be visible on top of the ground and we
don't really want that because that will
be a visual blockage and won't really be
looking good at all right so to do that
you have to like you know Loop through
that whole uh planes and disable them
one by one
so we are going to write a for each Loop
so inside that forage Loop we are going
to reference all the planes that are
being created so to do that where plane
in plane manager
dot trackables okay and once uh you have
got those claims what you have to do is
you have to disable them one by one so
I'm gonna call play Dot Game object dot
set active
I set it to false so whenever the like
how much like whatever number of planes
that have been generated they get
disabled as soon as I touch the
particular screen okay and then what we
want to do is after the plays have been
disabled we wanna disable the plane
match of clean manager dot enabled
equals
Fox so that way uh after like you know
after you've disabled the planes we are
disabling the plane manager because we
don't want any more planes to visit
okay and now that we are done with the
script what you can do is you can simply
save this particular script and go to a
Unity engine editor
and just make sure you have added all
the flowers and also all the like you
know components that were there that is
the managers you have added all the
managers once you have done all of that
what you can do is you can simply uh you
know change your scene name to main you
can also call it app or anything you
want and then go to file
build settings click on ADD open scenes
or you can simply drag and drop the
scene in here
then go to player settings and change
the product name to anything you want
now I'm going to name it garden flowers
you can change it to anything you like
right
and once that has been done you can
simply click on build and start building
the application right there okay and I'm
also going to attach a demo of this
whole project at the very end so that
you are able to see what we have built
during this project and if you have any
doubt make sure to join our Discord
server or you can uh like you know email
me you can go through my LinkedIn and
ask me there also you can ask it on my
Instagram okay and so I hope that you
have enjoyed this particular project I
will see you in the next part thank you
hey everyone welcome to this lecture in
this lecture I am going to teach you
about building and furniture-based Tryon
application so in this application the
base idea is that you will be able to
place multiple different Furnitures at
your room with the help of again AR
foundation and AR code and apart from
that we will also be able to switch
between those Furnitures with the help
of three different buttons that we will
be designing in this project video
now the challenge in this video is uh
what happens generally whenever you are
like you know let's say we ignore the
very basic things right just with the
simple placement stuff so what basically
is going to happen if you uh like you
know touch on the UI buttons it it is
going to react with the touchscreen all
right by that what I mean is let's say
you are trying to like you know Place
some object you have placed it and then
you are trying to switch switch into
some other Furniture also right so once
you are tapping that button even while
tapping that button it is going to place
that furniture in there which is a big
Challenge and I'm going to show you how
to solve that problem easily in this
particular lecture and of course there
are a lot of things that we are going to
learn and I hope that it clarifies all
the doubts you have till now with uh
like you know plane managers they cast
and all of those stuff right uh so
without any further Ado let's move
forward and set up the project Source
the very first thing you have to do is
you have to go to file then build
settings then switch it to Android now
this is the usual settings that we do
before uh building or you can say uh
start coding our project so you have to
again do that uh whole process again I'm
gonna show it to you again so that won't
be a problem
now once your build platform has been
switched to Android the next thing you
have to do is you have to install the AR
foundation and the AR code XR plugin so
to do that just go to Windows uh then
package manager go to your Unity
registry now it will take a few seconds
to fetch the recent packages right uh so
give it the time it needs and once it
does that what you have to do is search
for AR Foundation
now install that particular plugin and
once AR Foundation has been installed
you have to install something called AR
codex now let's say if you also want to
build for uh like you know iOS devices
then along with the AR core plugin you
also have to install AR kit plugin right
other than that uh there's the only
difference is that you have to set up
the build settings uh for iOS separately
that's that's it there are no more like
you don't have to put any more changes
uh within your project
so once AR Foundation has been installed
you have to install AR code XR plugin so
search for it simply install it that's
it
now once both of these plugins are
installed the next thing you have to do
is you have to go to edit then I think
it was Project settings yeah you have to
go to the project settings
then you have to go to this uh player
setting whereability yeah here it is so
you have to go to this player settings
now the more easier way would be if you
if you go to file then build settings
then directly so like you know click on
this player setting either way you will
be getting to the same settings as
required now once you are into the
player setting way what you have to do
is you have to go to resolution and
presentation and change the default
orientation to Portrait because this is
not an landscape orientation application
so we need a portrait uh apart from that
you have to go to other settings
uh uncheck this Auto Graphics API
because as of now uh welcome is not
really supported but uh recently uh at
Google I O Google announced that in the
future versions of AR code will be
supporting one but the current version
we are using doesn't really support uh
well you can graphic save me so simply
just removed now apart from that we got
multi-threader rendering uncheck it we
don't need it then from there you have
to go to this minimum API level uh
change it to Android 7.0 that is API
level 24 because that's the bare minimum
uh Android version AR code requires to
run apart from that we got the scripting
backend you have to change it to file to
CPP because currently it is set up in
mono and once you have done that you
have to go to this arm 64 and make sure
to check it right make sure it is
enabled because arm 64 helps you get the
64-bit architecture support now from
there uh yeah almost every settings is
settings are configured the next thing
you have to do is you have to go to
exact plugin management and make sure to
turn on AR code plugin provider and
that's it your project that is build
settings is set up properly now what you
have to do is you have to add the
current scene to your build setting so
I'm simply gonna click on ADD open
scenes so that way we set up our whole
build process
now let's import the assets right let's
design the UI first then we will get
into the coding part so again I have
packaged the assets into a small Unity
package called Sony ER dot Unity package
now all these assets are already
available in the LMS so you to download
these assets you have to go to the LMS
and get these assets for yourself
now just simply drag and drop this Sony
share asset or you can say Unity package
into your project folder and simply
click on import the next thing you have
to do is just simply go to the assets
folder you will be finding two more
different phones one is for the UI it
contains three different UI buttons and
then we have the Furnitures which
actually contain uh the models that we
have now if you like you know see on
your right side
you should be able to see this small
window for visualizing the precepts now
in most of the cases it might happen
that you might not find this window
that's because uh sometimes it's
minimized so you have to go at the
bottom and you can see that there's this
two very small lines you have to drag it
to the top and you will be able to
visualize uh your furniture mod okay
similarly I got another one that is this
light brown one and then again there's
another one called this white show for
now this white sofa looks much better
than the other three of course but uh
yeah this is how you can visualize these
sofas and you can also drag and drop it
to the scene if you want okay now let's
delete it for now because we are not
gonna need it as of now the next thing
we have to do is we have to create the
user interface okay now the base idea
behind the user interface would be uh to
switch between these models right to
switch between these three models now
let's create the UI first
the very first thing you have to do that
I would suggest right this is what I
actually do is I dock my game window
window to the right side okay then from
there you can see there's this drop down
call three aspect right now we don't
really need this free aspect what we
want is we want to use our template now
if you haven't really added a template
uh like you know a custom template to
your game window you can either use one
of the already provided templates but I
have added a few of these in my Unity
project so I'm going to use that
shifted to one of my templates and once
the template is open there's another
thing you should do is uh in the scene
window you should be able to find this
2D mode okay so simply switch uh to the
2D mode because that won't be any
helpful while designing the user
interfaces or doing anything in 2D okay
so once these are done the next thing
you have to do is you have to create a
canvas now simply right click in the
hierarchy go to UI and then create a
canvas component or you can say canvas
gain object now once you've created a
canvas there are two things okay one is
this canvas now this canvas is
responsible for uh like you know setting
up the UI and doing all the stuff
regarding the UI but this event system
is a very important part
the reason why it is very important the
event system actually handles all the
events that is happening within your
user interface right for example the tap
of a button if this event system is not
available what is gonna happen is you
will not be able to interact with the
user interface at all so it is very
important to have the event system if
you want to interact with the UI within
your uh like you know Unity project
but apart from that that's it and now if
we take a look at the canvas we got this
something called canvas scalar now in
here you should be able to find
something called UI scale mode this is a
very important thing okay because
constant constant pixel size is like you
know doesn't really make your UI
response so you have to change it to
scale with screen size which is gonna
help you like you know create a more
responsive user interface for your
application
once you've switched your like you know
UI scan mode to scale with screen size
the next thing you actually have to do
is uh like you know create three buttons
now you can either use the default
buttons that Unity or text message Pro
provides us with but here's what I would
suggest is going for an image then
adding a button component to it it makes
it much more easier because uh if you if
you go with a button component uh you I
mean a predefined button by unity or
text message Pro it's gonna take you a
lot of time just to set the UI to it
delete and that's a lot of hassle that
we don't want to go right now into Okay
so
here's what we are going to do select
the canvas right click go to UI add an
image okay now I think the proper size
of the image would be 200 by 200 so
simply go to the this width and height
option and change it to 200 by 21 okay
and then add a button component okay see
without the button component
this uh like you know image will just be
an image so we need this particular
button component uh to be able to dis to
be able to provide the button
functionality to this particular image
okay so once that is done you can change
its name to some like you know maybe uh
to one of your prefabs or you can say
one of your Furnitures so I'm gonna name
this one uh white sofa because that is
one of the Furnitures and once you uh
name this just save your C
and then the next thing you have to do
is you have to Anchor it okay you have
to Anchor this particular image or you
can say this button to the bottom left
of your uh UI so again to do it simply
press alt on your keyboard then indirect
transform component you can see that
this Center Middle option in here right
so select that wrist alt and then simply
select this bottom left option and you
can see that this particular UI
component got anchored at the bottom
left of the UI now duplicate it
now name it yellow I think it was
something called yellow light brown so
if I guess yeah it was light brown sofa
that now what you have to do is you have
to Anchor it to the center
so again press alt on your keyboard
select the same option then anchor it to
the center okay now again duplicate it
after duplicating it change its name to
Brown sofa
then select the anchor again press alt
then put it like you know
to the right side or you can say the
bottom right of the UI candles
the next thing you would want to do is
select all these three and uh change its
position y to maybe 200 uh is 200 too
big maybe uh let's go for 150 yeah 150
same reason reasonable and from there
select the white sofa change its
position X to 150 and select the Browns
over and again change Brown surface
position it's the minus one quickly okay
so that way we got a pretty even uh user
interface okay
now the next thing you would want to do
is to apply this price or you can say
the button images to these special
button okay so select the white Sosa now
in here you should be able to find
something called Source image now here's
a little dot in here so select that dot
and you should be able to find all the
in like you know Sprite or images that
are already available so I'm going to
search for sofa right here and you can
see that we got the option for three
different so-calls now the first button
would be for the white sofa so I'm going
to select the white four
the second one would be for the light
brown sofa so I'm gonna
you know check for the light brown sofa
and then I'm gonna check for for the
third one I'm gonna check for the simple
Brown sofa and again it is already
available on the top so I don't really
have to search point
add this way you set up your user
interface properly okay now the next
thing we have to do is
the next thing we have to do is we have
to write this to it okay now there are a
few things that you have always have to
keep in mind and before that
we actually have to set up our steel
okay we created the UI the next thing we
have to do is we have to set up our C so
delete the main camera because main
camera is not for augmented reality
you have to add like you know AR sound
sorry AR session origin and AR session
so simply right click in the hierarchy
go to XR add an a session origin and
then again add an AR session
now drag and drop both of these to the
top because this just a convention that
I follow it like you know it makes
things much more simpler simpler for me
and much more organized Palm
now once you have select this AR session
origin we have to add two different
components okay now both of these
components are very necessary for like
you know placing the objects into the
real world
so let's see how you can do the same so
the very first thing you have to add is
an array cast manager okay now array
cast manager would be responsible for
shooting the raycasts that would at the
very end would help you place the
objects at a particular position okay
the next thing you have to add is an AR
plane manager
okay now the AR plane manager would be
responsible for detecting your real
ground right your real surface and then
it would be responsible for generity
artificial planes on top of it okay and
also reset the Transformers area
foundation that would be much better
but yeah
these are the responsibilities of AR
Carson Azure and AR plane
okay
the next thing I would suggest is to
create three different folders one for
materials one for prefabs and one for
scripts now of course I have my reason
so we will get into that now create a
folder for called materials okay
create another folder called uh prefabs
sorry I think I named it wrong yeah
these ads then create another Fork
uh scripts okay now scripts will be
storing the script files the prefabs
will be storing the prefabing files and
the material for restoring the material
sites okay now the next thing we want to
do is we want to visualize the planes
that are being generated okay so how can
you do that it's again pretty simple
just right click in the hierarchy go to
Exotic add an AR default clip okay
simply uh the next thing what you can do
is you can assign a material to it it
already has a material okay but I
wouldn't really suggest you going for
that material so go to your materials
folder
create a new material so I'm gonna
create a new material I'm gonna call it
cleaner okay now I want it to be
transparent so in the in the materials
I'm gonna go to rendering mode change
its uh change it to transparent and then
I'm gonna like you know
convert its also value to full zero okay
now the next thing I want to do is I am
going to select this AR default name go
to its material section simply drag and
drop my material up in here
and then if I go to presack I simply
have to drag and drop this AR default
plane into the prefabs folder and it
will be converted into a preset okay
now once that has been done go to your
AR session origin and add this AR
default link to this plane prefer a
preference variable okay
so this is it we actually properly set
up our whole project so that it can
support your foundation and we also set
up our UI so what's next okay the next
thing is we have to now learn to place
the object right switch between those
objects and we have to switch it in a
way so that it doesn't really affect the
placement of our objects okay because uh
there is a technique to do that now what
uh requirements am I saying this now if
you like you know if you use this simple
placement stuff that I taught you in the
previous lecture video
okay if you configure it to place a
different object switch between uh like
you know those furniture by click of a
UI button there will still be a problem
the problem is let's say when you are
pressing any sort of button in the UI
okay it's still gonna place it
it's of course it's gonna change but
it's still gonna place it when when you
are pressing at that button now that is
not a behavior we want the behavior we
want is when we are pressing on the
buttons it should only change these
Furniture okay it shouldn't place at the
moment we only want to place it when we
uh like you know tap on a screen outside
of these buttons so that's the
functionality we are looking for okay
now of course the script is totally same
as it was for the previous lecture just
with a few modifications and in the
previous lecture I forgot uh to write a
piece of code okay which is uh very
necessary right of course it won't break
the functionality within your
application it won't crash your
application but it's a better option to
do it because without that it's gonna
throw an exception so let's
let's start writing our script okay so
you have to create a script I'm gonna
name it uh like you know let's say
what's your name let's name it furniture
place or manage okay so I'm going to
name it furniture
placement
manager
okay
now simply open the script in your
Visual Studio code and once you've
opened it
just remove the start and update method
okay because believe me it just makes
things much more uh like you know
cluttering just a second it's uh so
returning some errors for some reason so
let me restart the editor once
because sometimes it happens with Visual
Studio code this doesn't really happens
with visual studio all the time but it I
have seen it happening with Visual
Studio code all the way so yeah let's
remove
the start and update method
the next thing you want to do is you
want to define a few variables okay but
before that you have to include a few
namespaces now there are two very
important namespaces because they give
us the functionality they give us access
to the apis
foundation okay so you have to write
these two lines that is using
Unity engine
dot x r dot AR foundation and also add a
dot exact dot AR subsystems okay
so these are the two namespaces we are
gonna require for now of course there
are two more namespaces that we need to
include but we will go like you know go
into that later on in this video itself
okay so you have to sing
the functionality is the same that is we
have to implement the touch
functionality we have to shoot a recast
to place the objects we also have to
implement a a simple function to switch
between uh like you know these
furnitures
apart from that there's another thing
that is we have to make sure whenever we
are pressing the UI button we don't
place that object at that very moment
okay so let's write the code for it so
let's create the reference variables at
first first of all I'm gonna create a
reference variable which will be storing
our default Furniture okay so I'm gonna
call it public
uh game object
spawnable furniture
okay the next thing we are going to do
is we are going to Define a variable
that will be referring by referencing
the AR session origin and I'm gonna call
it session i j again I'm going to do the
same for the AR recast manager and I'm
gonna call it raycast manager and then
again the same for uh the plane manager
vessel AR
plane management when I'm gonna call it
plane manager okay and I'm also going to
create a private list of raycast hits
right so whenever we are shooting any
sort of recast into the real world it
gets stored in this particular news
because we will be accessing this
cleanest to get the positional data so
private
list
array cast hit
I'm going to call it recast hits equals
new Nest requested and voila we actually
uh initialized all the particular
variables that we are gonna need okay so
save the script to go to your Unity
engine
and let it load
now make sure to attach the script to
your AR session origin
now simply drag and drop the components
in me here that is my session noise and
then the recast manager and then the
plane manager and select the default
furniture and you can like you know
select this particular dot option in
here go to the assets and select the
default formation you want to have now I
want to have the white sofa as the
default Furniture okay so as select like
you know set the respawnable for nature
to the white sofa now once these are
done
we have to write uh the functionality so
that we are able to place the object
into the real okay so I'm gonna explain
the logic very briefly so keep your ears
open and try to understand it properly
so write this update method
the very first thing you have to check
for and this is what I missed in the
previous lecture okay you have to check
for if there are any touch on the screen
okay then only you have to look for
where if the like you know if the person
has touched on it or not okay
so first of all you have to look for if
there are any sort of touch that has
happened or is is happening within your
particular application so to do that you
have to write this if condition if input
Dot
uh touch count
is greater than zero okay and if there
are one or more touches what we want to
do is we wanna uh start that is we want
to check if the touch has happened or
not okay so if input dot get touch
zero sorry uh you have to put 0 as a
parameter because we wanna get the very
first touch and then touch dot CS equals
equals touch face dot began okay so that
way whenever you tap on the screen this
particular function is being called okay
now inside this function we have to
shoot a raycast
so raycast manager
daughter a cast
now inside this you have to provide them
like you know touch position now in the
previous lecture I showed you that you
can use the input.mouse function but in
this I'm also going to show you the
other way around that is
input.getouch.position okay now there
are not many difference in it the only
difference is that the input dot mouth
position Works universally that is it
will work for Windows uh MacBooks or any
sort of platform right uh where the
touch is happening but this
input.getouch.position only happens
on your Android or iOS device that has a
touchscreen okay so let's do it so input
dot get touch
zero dot position
the next thing you have to do is you
have to pass the recast hits and then
you have to set the trackable type
to plane width polygon okay
now once it shows the raycast and the
raycast has hit that particular ground
it's going to return return us uh
Boolean value okay that is either it has
hit that particular generated plane or
not so we are gonna write a Boolean
Collision variable okay to detect if the
Collision has happened
and if the Collision has happened what
we generally want to do is
we wanna place that object to the
position and the like you know to the
position of the raycast and uh to the
position a rotation of that request okay
so it's Collision
has happened
what we want to do is we want to
instantiate the game of the quest so I'm
gonna name it object equals
instantiate
spawnables furniture
then I'm gonna set the transform I mean
the position of this particular object
to the position of the recast head so
object.transform dot position equals
uh what was it point
the cast hits
0 dot pose
dot position okay now I'm gonna do the
same but for this time for the rotation
okay
so I'm gonna simply name the position to
rotation do the same for the this
particular object now once that has been
done
this will actually help us place the
object onto the real world okay apart
from this there's another thing that we
have to do is whenever we have placed
our first object we want to disable the
planes right we don't wanna because if
the planes are still visible even after
placing that object it's going to make
the experience very much unrealistic and
we don't want unrealism if we are going
to build a very immersive uh augmented
reality application
so to do that
you have to Loop through though the
place that has been generated so for
each
where planes
in planemanager dot trackables now these
trackables actually store all the planes
that has been generated so you have to
do it like this names Dot Game object
dot set active
solves okay that way you can set all the
game all the plays that has been
generated to false and the last thing
you have to do is you have to disable
the plane manager so that no more
artificial planes are generated
foreign
false now you can save your script okay
you can simply save your script and load
it in unity but there are a few more
things that you have to do okay
the first thing you have to do is you
have to be able to switch between these
Furnitures okay so open your script
again
see this function is pretty simple it's
just a one-liner code you have to create
a public function that is public
void
switch Furniture let's call it to its
furniture for now okay then you have to
pass a game object as a parameter I'm
going to call it for your niche
now you can simply what you can do is
you can reference respawnable furniture
that is uh
conversation and set it to the furniture
of available as a parameter okay now
save it go to your Unity engine
now select the UI buttons that you have
add an action event action to this on
click function drag and drop your AR
session origin go to this particular
function uh select the furniture
placement manager and then click on
switch formation okay then select the
white sofa go to this white dot and
sealing the white silver prefab now do
the same for the light brown one too
then again the same for the brown soup
now once these are done you should be
able to successfully switch between
those objects okay but this is still a
problem okay now see this script is
enough for you to be able to place uh
like you know data planes then Place uh
these Furnitures over to your place but
right now the problem that persist is
even if you click like while you are
clicking on the UI
let's say if I am clicking on the UI
right now the object will be placed at
that moment now this is not something we
want there's a very unexpected behavior
and a very bad uh Behavior also we don't
want that kind of behavior and
application you have to create a very
simple Boolean function that would check
if your own button has been placed or
not okay and if your button has been
pressed I mean if your button is being
pressed you don't want to place at that
moment if your button is not being
pressed then only you wanna place it
okay
so you have to write this particular
function public move is the return type
of that function because we will be
returning a Boolean type that is either
it would either be of false or either be
a true
and then you have to name that function
I'm going to call it is button rest
now before writing the code inside it
okay you have to add
two more names faces one is for uh the
you accessing the UI button that is
using Unity engine
dot UI
then also add an event system per unit
because that's how we will be accessing
the button so Unity engine
dot I think it was called event sisters
yeah
this is it
now once you have added these two
namespaces right here let's code this
particular function okay
so if
even system
dot current
dot uh
current selected uh game object
now we are going to put this question
mark in here now this question mark
isn't is more of a short form for
knowledge check okay then we have to get
the component now I feel like if you
don't want to use this question mark you
can also use another option called try
get component but fauna as I have used
already use this question mark I'm gonna
use uh the get component in here okay so
get component
now inside this we have to get the
button component because that's uh
that's the UI components we will be
pressing on okay
then I'm gonna check if it has null okay
now if the button is null we want to
return false
that is if we haven't pressed on the
button we want to return false and if we
have pressed on it then we are gonna
return true okay as simple as that
now the next thing you have to do is you
have to go to this if condition where
the Collision is being checked you have
to add this and operator and then
you have to check if the like you know
button press is false or not so is
button pressed
equals equals false
so that way we have completed our script
and this script is actually gonna help
us to place the object properly without
the UI interfering us anymore okay the
next thing you have to do is you have to
click on sign click on build settings
then if you already haven't added the
sample scene you have to add that
particular scene you are working on
then you have to click on build
and make you know you can name anything
your build now the better way this is uh
I like you know I make use of this
particular method I create a new folder
okay I create a new folder called uh
bills
now this builds folder contains all the
bits that I need okay that way it's uh
like I am able to keep track of all the
bits that I have built in the previous
uh like you know implementations that
way I can test for the bugs and all of
that so it's a pretty handful method
so yeah that's about it this will build
the application and after it builds I
will try it on and put a like you know
attach a video of the demo to uh
to to the end of this video so that's it
for this lecture thank you